[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes
brought to you by spectator tv and
broadcast on thursday july 1st
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show sajit javid has
taken over as health secretary
after matt hancock was found to have
broken his own coveted rules
are the restrictions being applied
fairly we'll speak to former
international trade secretary
and mp for north somerset dr liam fox
and our deputy political editor katie
balls will give us a politics update
and is anywhere safe for uyghur muslims
in this week's magazine journalist
harold mass
tells the tragic stories of weakers
being extradited from countries across
the world and imprisoned in camps in
china
he joins us here on spectator tv eu
leaders clashed last week in brussels
over a new hungarian law that
bans schools displaying content about
homosexuality
to under-18s with angela merkel leaving
in september and macron's prospects of
re-election looking questionable
who will keep the block together and
finally
what if the now infamous matt hancock
video had been a fake
in this week's magazine the journalist
isabel oakshot says she turned down the
chance to use the footage
because she was worried it was doctored
she'll be on the show
all that to come in the next hour but
before we get going if you enjoy what we
do on spectator tv
then subscribe to our youtube channel
click the button at the bottom of this
video
and then tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
and if you want to subscribe to the
magazine take up our 12 issues for 12
pound offer
you'll get three months of the spectator
in print and online for just 12 pounds
plus we'll give you a 20 pound amazon
voucher completely free
just go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer to take it up
now first former chancellor sajit javid
was appointed health secretary after
matt hancock
was caught breaking coveted rules in his
office so what's the mood of the tory
party like and will the new health
secretary be more keen to end
restrictions than his predecessor
i'm joined now by the conservative mp
and former international trade secretary
dr liam fox
liam thank you for joining spectator tv
so it's been a week of revelations
others might say rank hypocrisy after
hancock was discovered to be breaking
the rules he mandated the nation follow
how damaging has this been to the tory
party's reputation
and to the public's willingness to keep
following the rules
i think the public are willing to follow
the law i think that's one of the
key characteristics of the british
people i think that what
is irritating people at the moment is
that they see the rules
uh being applied in a very asymmetric
way
too many exemptions for reasons that are
not entirely clear
and a suspicion that we are now
following
dates not data you tweeted yesterday
that while brits are welcome in france
if they've had two jabs
they have to isolate when they come back
meanwhile uefa officials come into the
uk
and don't have to isolate nor do
apparently senior business executives if
they're thought to be economically
beneficial to the uk
strange languages i'm pretty sure small
businesses play a vital role
to the uk economy too it just doesn't
seem fair does it
it doesn't seem fair because it isn't
fair um
if you can go to france having had two
jabs because as public health england
have told us
these jobs will cover you against all
the known variants
and the french think that's perfectly
reasonable
that's one case you can't then come back
from france
with the same two jabs that cover you
for all the known variants to the uk
for reasons that i can't quite fathom
and i think it's that
lack of clarity and transparency that
irritates people
and i think people especially in places
like the travel industry
they are not stupid they can read the
data themselves
if we know the criteria on which these
decisions are being taken
then people can monitor uh the trends
and they can get an idea of where we're
going i think it's the
uh arbitrary nature of some of these
decisions um the way that they change
with without much notice
and the fact that we're not clear uh
about the criteria
because there's a lack of transparency i
think that is
potentially a way to undermine public
support and
it can so easily be managed uh i was
saying in the house of commons a couple
of days ago
we need better data right at the
beginning you'll remember we were told
so many people were admitted to
hospitals so many had pre-existing
conditions and so on now we're just told
about the case numbers and the case
numbers themselves
don't actually tell us anything if
they're all children
aged between 5 and 12 that's not going
to overrun the nhs is it
we should know which groups are actually
being admitted as
is it people for example who could have
been immunized but chose not to be
and in the hospitalization numbers how
long are people being admitted for
what's the net
number of people in hospital uh inflow
and outflow how many of them require
further treatment how many go on to icu
all these are bits of information
that would enable the public and
parliament to understand better
the nature of the decisions being taken
and all i'm asking for
which i think is not unreasonable is the
fair application of the rules
and greater transparency about decision
taking
and what data that is actually being
based upon
i think that most people would think
that was an entirely sensible and
reasonable thing to ask for
i suppose those who would defend these
exemptions would say
look at wembley this week where we saw
spectacular scenes of the england team
beating the german team
it was a wonderful moment for the nation
a huge boost to morale
uefa were threatening to take the
semifinals and finals
out of the country if they didn't get
their exemptions for thousands of vip
guests
perhaps they defend it by saying well
this trade-off was worth it
well it may well be defensible
politically it may well be defensible in
terms of people's enjoyment
is it consistent with with the rules on
public health
apparently it is but on what criteria
i think that we have actually moved from
being
having decisions taken based on data to
decisions taken
by date and my problem with that is that
i think that the data increasingly says
we could be unlocking before the 19th of
july
and we should be looking at that data
we're getting increasing evidence
that the hospitalization and the death
rates are not rising in anything like
the same
proportions as the number of cases we
have there's clearly a break in the link
which is what you'd expect
when you've got a vaccine that covers
you against most of the variants
in fact all the known variants that we
have at the present time
and it seems to me that having begun the
vaccination program so early and having
given the british people a great
advantage that the government are
squandering that to an extent and that
what could have been a great vaccine
dividend for the british people
is being denied by an over-application
of the precautionary principle and at
some point
you know i'm i'm a medic you know before
i was a politician
the medical profession will want to
drive the numbers down to the lowest
possible
level that's not the same aim as the
government the government needs to be
to make sure that the there's not a
higher level of infection there needs to
be
in at a level that's consistent with the
opening up of the economy
the maintenance of people's jobs the
running of the health service to a more
efficient level
dealing with some of the groups left
behind getting our children back to
school
and making sure that our families and
friends can be reunited because that's a
vital part
of our social and mental health so the
government's aims have to diverge
from their medical advisors aims at some
point i think we're at that point
it does seem increasingly likely that
the 19th of july will go ahead
after this four week delay but how free
will we actually be
liam because it's clear that
international travel is certainly not
resuming
normal services anytime soon and if
people are worried about getting pinged
by test and trace and having to
self-isolate for nearly two weeks
their behavior may not return to normal
well there is a very big question
uh about tests and trace if we're not
actually in a public health emergency
and all our restrictions are lifted
after the 19th of july
what business is it of the state where
citizens go to eat
or drink and there's a question then
about the validity
uh or and and the justification
politically and morally
of that system if we don't have a public
health emergency that it's underpinning
so i think there'll be quite a big
debate around that
there's a new health secretary in town
now sachit chaved with your
medic hat on as well as your politics
hat on
what do you make of this appointment and
do you think he's going to be giving you
the data that you were just talking
about that you're so desperate to see
well he did say in an answer to my
question in the house of commons that
yes
we would see more data so that would be
a great thing in fact i think it's a
good thing all around
the the more that we can show why
decisions are taken
and people can understand uh the data
and empirical basis for decision making
the more there's likely to be acceptance
of those decisions so
i i hope that we we get that we are
entering a different phase
uh and it's a chance for sergio javid to
make his name i think as health
secretary by
taking the public and parliament more
into the trust of the government and i
think that would be a good thing all
around
for the public for parliament and for
the government you also said in the
comments this week that parliament needs
to be taken in
confidence i think you're hinting at it
here but to what extent do you think
that the government
has been ignoring its backbench mps
during this crisis
i don't think it's it's ignoring i think
it's just that we've had this odd
dynamic of
announcements being made by downing
street press conference rather than
proper discussion in the house of
commons we don't have proper debates in
the house of commons
because the system is being altered
because of covert
i think that one of the things that we
need to get if we're going to hold the
government properly to account
are changes in parliament itself having
ministerial statements where you get one
question but no follow-up
is no way to scrutinize an executive and
we need parliament to
go back to normal as quickly as we we
can get it
so that the government can be held to
account and
and we can ensure that we get the
information that we want so we would all
win
um from that parliament would be uh
functioning better the public would be
better represented
and the government would actually
function better as governments always do
when they're being properly held to
account even if they don't enjoy the
process
let's assume that at some point the
rules that apply to the powerful
will apply to everyone else as we've
been discussing
are you worried about a system that
creates perks for
the double jabs creating a new two-tier
system in its place essentially the jab
versus the jab knots
well the aim then of course is for
everyone to take up the
the jabbing i've had mine um i would
advise everybody
um to get it um it's no there's no
compunction
in britain for people to get it but
people who don't get
their immunization can't expect for
example to have the same international
travel
as people who do get it that's always
been the case if for example
you decided you didn't want to get a
yellow fever jab you couldn't go to
certain places in africa
so the principal's no different from
before and i think that
people are perfectly entitled if they
choose
not to get the job they should think
about their own health and they should
think about
public health as part of their civic
responsibility
but if they choose not to get it that's
their right but they also have to
understand that with rights will come
responsibilities
and consequences we've seen
vaccine passports coming into the uk
without really so much of a discussion
in parliament at wembley for example you
either have to show
your job status or you have to show a
negative cova test this has not been
properly debated does that worry you
well
again i think that parliament needs to
be given more time
and better uh conditions to to properly
have these debates
the way in which we've been doing
virtual parliament which has basically
restricted us to three minutes is
what i sometimes refer to as the cbb's
parliament with a three-minute attention
span
um i think that needs to change um and i
think we need to be able to discuss
these things
uh more widely and in more depth than we
can
with the time limits that we have at the
present uh in parliament so
uh that needs to change um as for the
international element i think that's
well established so i think people who
don't have a jab
uh can't expect to have the same
international travel rights
and we have a right as a country to
expect people coming in to be able to
prove
that they've been immunized if they want
to be free to travel within the uk
the difficulty then comes as you alluded
to
about different differential rights in
the country between those who've had
jobs and those who haven't
that i think as you say has not been
really properly debated
and there are all sorts of conflicting
things there about the rights of
private companies of private facilities
to determine who comes in
to their facility so it's it's a complex
debate
uh which as i say requires a lot more
than we've been able to have in
parliament so far
last question liam i hate to bring it up
but there is already talk about upping
restrictions this winter to curb the
virus
what data would you need to see
including a surge in infections
or hospitalizations to decide whether or
not we need another lock down dare i say
or at least more restrictions again well
if you saw
another covert variant different to what
to what we've had before that wasn't
just more transmissible
but was actually more deadly then you'd
have to think about it again
that's unlikely because the way that
viruses mutate
largely by genetic drift rather than
genetic shift
is is a generally is a slower process
and i think that you can expect that
these vaccines will
be effective for some time you may need
a booster jab
but but it will give a lot of protection
to the population
we will face um in all likelihood an
increase in the number of seasonal
infections that's not a reason to
put restrictions back on the population
we've gone through flu
pandemics when we didn't do that and i
don't think there would be a
justification for doing it
and i think governments have to be very
very careful
that they don't use the justifications
of a public health emergency to restrict
our freedoms
and then apply that to conditions which
cannot really be described
as public health emergencies but are
more an inconvenience
i think we've got to be very clear about
um our differentiation in those in those
cases
liam thank you so much for joining me
pleasure thank you
and i'm now joined by the spectator's
deputy political editor katie balls to
react to some of that
and to give us our westminster update
katie it could have been a very
difficult week for the conservative
party given the scandal that was
revealed related to its health secretary
but it seems the appointment of sacha
javid has calmed things down
what are you making of it yes i mean i
think the appointment of sergey javid as
the new health secretary is
very popular among tory back benches in
part because matt hancock was not
particularly popular amongst tory back
benches
there has long been a sense particularly
from lockdown skept victoria mps
that matt hancock was the chief dove the
one pushing for the strictest
restrictions and clears is in part
because his brief is health as opposed
to something that she's seen i can
charge the economy
but i think the fact you now have
someone coming in
in the form of jab that he's spoken
about running their economy hot
about balancing at the cost of
harms caused by lockdown so rise in
domestic abuse
um with uh the effect of covert that i
think is adding to this sense that
actually we're moving to a new stage of
the pandemic
i think there's still some tricky
questions for boris johnson i think that
you can see the opposition parties want
to make hay from the fact that
boris johnson initially stuck by matt
hancock when those photos and later
video emerged of him uh you know
breaching
covert restrictions of his married
female advisor
um but generally speaking in terms of
the tory party at least is has landed
fairly well and katie you've been
writing about how
uh the appointment of sacha javed is
going to change the dynamic in
cabinet as you say matt hancock was the
chief
dub sachit javid is more in rishi
sunak's camp isn't he when it comes to
being slightly more bullish
taking on more risk and wanting to
really open up yes i think that's what
all of sergio jeva's previous comments
suggest if you look at his interventions
from the back benches
i remember he left the role of
chancellor uh quite early on when she's
soon i've moved in
and from the back benches he has argued
about you know
not having restrictions for too long and
actually lifting those
but i think it's worth pointing out that
these comments were in relation to the
economy
now since uh you know getting this role
we saw sergey javid and his debut in the
commons talk about
the uh the july dates in 19th july as
not just a terminus date he said as the
end of the line so i think
the tone of the language i think is
stronger than matt hancock
however i do think we have to remember
that now
that what sergeant javed is going to be
seeing is all the
problems all the pressure particularly
from figures such as
chris witty when it comes to
difficulties so while i think he's a
hawk by nature
it's obviously a bit easier to say there
when you're looking at from an economic
perspective
i do think that sergey javid is very
keen for restrictions to come to an
end i think his appointment increases
the chance of 19 july going ahead but
i think it was likely to go ahead anyway
so the thing to look for
is there's lots of bits tied up in this
so the working from home guidance
uh rules and self-isolation and they're
in a way what uh makes you know freedom
day free more
feel more free depending on which bits
go um and i
and i think that sajid java's
appointment is good news um
for those trying to make sure it is a
fuller freedom day rather than slower in
terms of more easings
so if there's growing consensus that the
19th of july has to restore these
freedoms
is the new political battle what happens
this winter as our colleague james
forsyth
writes in this week's magazine ministers
are already talking about what could be
required
come winter if infections and
hospitalizations started to rise
and we heard from liam fox there that
he'll keep an open mind on it that he
would
certainly not be keen to go back into a
lockdown or to up restrictions but a lot
of it will depend
on what the data does is is this the new
political battle
correct here yeah i mean i think that is
the big battle we're heading towards i
still think there's going to be a few
bumps
uh for example at the moment the
self-isolation policy
is only uh the people who would be able
to avoid it i think would only be the
double vaccinated
and there's still a lot of young people
who want to go out and enjoy their lives
who
could be told to isolate for 10 days
um for going to an area and obviously
increased chance there's no social
distancing so
i think that this can bounce back to
complete normality isn't going to happen
while you have quite strict
self-isolation rules
i think you also have a row over schools
um what is the system
for pupils going to be and because that
is very dysfunctional if you look at the
number
missing school because of these bubble
rules we expect new rules
but um more testing i speak to tory mpc
say no the answer is to not test pupils
given they are low risk and people be
double vaccinated
but the government is talking about more
tests now so i think there's a few
battles like that um then i think the
big one is
if the winter is going to be as bad as
chris whittie the chief medical officer
is telling
ministers privately as well as making
some reference to you publicly
and how do you deal with that we know
that boris johnson and sanji javed are
saying this is all irreversible
but yet there are plenty of figures in
government who aren't particularly
dovers who are just
quite worried about the prospect of this
the combination of flu
and potentially bouts of pneumonia mixed
with covert and i think that is going to
be bumpy and
and i think as james says in the
magazine this week probably sadly
jabba's biggest challenge in the role
this year
thank you katie while we're focusing on
what's happening here at home
harold mass writes in this week's
magazine about china's horrific
manhunt of the weaker muslims the
minority group
which beijing has been imprisoning in
so-called re-education camps in xinyang
is now being hunted down by the chinese
communist party abroad
specifically in countries like turkey
and dubai that were previously safe
havens
harold is on the show now harold thank
you for joining us on spectator tv
in your piece you write about how the
ccp is following weakers around the
world
and then imprisoning them sending them
back to internment camps in china
can you tell us more about what's going
on yeah thank you the campaign
actually against the uigurus which
happens in china in
in western china it's already quite
known
but what i think is interesting about
this situation is
that china is expanding the situation
and this massive
crackdown and and some say
like ethnical genocide against uigurus
now on a worldwide scale and
shockingly this happens especially in
countries like in
muslim countries like egypt like
united arab emirates like saudi arabia
and there i spoke to people who families
who
lost contact to the loved ones who just
disappeared and this
have been transported back to china
and they're vanished in some of the
camps or
in prison and in your piece for the
magazine this week
you detail some of those examples what
has the weaker experience been like
the experiences these are not from
my knowledge and also from lots of
interviews i did with uee gurus
in germany in other countries in
kazakhstan
these are not people who were
politically who
aged i who do any kind of work against
china
these are just normal families who try
to work who
who in dubai and do just normal work
and suddenly they get a call from the
local police in this case it was in
in dubai um a couple and
the guy was asked to to call report to
the
police station he's been he's been
living in dubai for many many years
and there he was arrested and his wife
had not
had not a chance to talk to him again he
she just saw him there
and a few weeks or months later he was
um extradited to china and um
most probably has been there sent to an
um re-education camp like hundreds of
thousands
people there as well so we're not
talking about dissidents we're not
talking about
political active people or whatever
we're just talking about normal families
and people who just disappeared in this
case the wife
she has not heard from her husband for
more than three years and of course she
talks to the chinese authorities
to the e to the um to the authorities in
dubai but she never gets an answer
and she herself had to flee as well
because this country became so
dangerous for um insecure for we were
people that she had to flee to turkey
there's obviously no situation where
these actions taken by the ccp
would be justified but this feels like
an important point to emphasize
they're not just targeting those who are
vocally opposed to the government or
actively campaigning against it
they're essentially targeting any and
all weakers going about their normal
lives
so in other words absolutely no weaker
is safe
exactly and and if this would be only
one case or two case you could argue
maybe the chinese government has some
knowledge which we don't have
but i talked over the years to to dozens
of families
um in mainly in countries close to china
and kazakhstan
where where the kazakh people same as we
go same from the region of xinjiang
getting sent to these camps and these
are people who are just sometimes some
are
retired have been retired and and they
get a call
and say oh there's some question about
your former job please come and report
to us
then they go back to xinjiang and they
disappear in a camp some went there for
family reunions some
one couple i talked to went for for for
a wedding
and um the guy never came back and
so these are just normal people and some
of them are even which is uh ironically
some of them are
even had been in the past supporters of
of
the government and had been members of
the communist party
but just that you are muslim and just
that you are like
member of the of the uigurus or kazakh
people in xinjiang
makes you basically brings you in danger
to getting sent to these camps
you report that some people are being
taken from places that have previously
been a refuge
to uighur muslims places like turkey and
egypt
what's changed turkey is still
in a sense the most uh refuge for
for uighur people and and the most
important country for uigurus
um to to to go there and live because
we google culture and language is very
close to the turkish they basically can
understand them that they
can understand turkish language and the
culture is very close
and um but these other countries you
just mentions
there there had been always a few
thousand people we
we were people who lived there and
apparently
and quite obviously the chinese
government is using its power
it's it's even growing economic
influence and whatever means that they
have
to to put pressure on these countries
and lots of pressure
to extradite these people back to to
china in some cases
chinese police people people from the
secret
uh police from china have been coming to
these
churches have been coming to egypt for
example and
interviewing these people and
questioning these people in the
in in in the prison and then before
they've been sent back
so what is happening that china is
basically expanding its campaign
against uighurs which is is happening
for more than three years um now in
xinjiang
on a global scale and the space for
uighurs to live is getting smaller and
smaller
because there are not so many countries
left one sentence may be about
about turkey because this is still the
most important place where
people can live you have to imagine
these people don't have passports
because they have chinese passports but
china stopped long
long time ago to renew these passports
so you
they don't have means to travel they
they basically stateless in a sense
and in turkey they've been saved but now
we can see there's lots of pressure on
turkey from the chinese side
to sign like some kind of agreements
where which would um make uigurus
bring them in the situation that they
have been sending them from turkey as
well to
back to china as if this weren't
distressing enough you also report
worryingly that the chinese government
is using official bodies like the
international criminal police
organization
to hunt down the uyghur muslims
how is the west allowing this to happen
um this this interpol you're mentioning
china is doing this for many years and
they're intensifying this basically
misusing international bodies and
international organizations
for bringing these people and for for
hunting for this kind of manhunt
if you want and one prominent case
is is the the president of the world we
google congress
which is the exile organization this is
not a political organization they are
based in germany
and and they are um this person like
dolken is a president
he was basically wanted by for more than
20 years by interpol
on the request on china and um to
and he was always when he traveled he
was in danger that he would go to some
country even
south korea and and then they've been
the risk of being sending back
the problem is that interpol is
international organization
and that they they don't check what the
member
states basically why they are hunting
somebody or why they
make a person like a wanted person and
if you like china want to misuse this
for political reason
then you have basically the situation
that people who
like talking easily for example he was
checked by the german government he's a
german citizen and he for
of course all the german secret service
and
everybody else was checking if he would
have some political
whatever he would be an activist or if
he would be like non-violent in any
sense
but they never there was never any proof
in this case
but still for he he was always at risk
being sending back
to china so is the west being lazy here
and in this case
and to an extent which could be deadly
for people
by not checking china's power when it
abuses these international systems
to uh to to understand it's not only
china misusing for example interpol in
this case
other other authority in authoring
states also misuse the system but china
is doing this massively
um it's it's of course
european countries they check very
carefully and they never sendings
they who is if they get like a red
notice this is how it's called
from interpol somebody's wanted from
which country it's coming and if this is
a country which misuses for political
reasons
and then um then they don't extradite
people
and um european countries have been
actually quite
quite open and they too for uyghurs and
they have been a lot of
people have been accepted as refugees so
i think it's not that the governments
are blind and they're doing their part
but the reality is that china is getting
much more powerful and the countries
which have
financial um economic interests
political interests with china
especially now with this the covet
crisis and a lot of countries
which are economically maybe not so
strong which are politically or
economically
depending on china especially now the
kovic crisis
where china is using its vaccination
and vaccination programs to put pressure
on some countries
then they just have to choose the
pressure is getting more and more
in some countries some you mentioned
like egypt saudi arabia
and the united arab emirates they
they are changing their policies and
basically they're handing over
these regular people to being sent back
to china where they disappear in the
camps or even in prison
and turkey is now somewhere in the
middle and it
depends on how will turkey will react
and
act in the next few months if
um turkey will still be like a safe
place for illegal people
and just to put into perspective what is
happening to the weakers when they
return
to china you've written for us before
highlighting the atrocities going on
inside these internment camps can you
tell us a bit about that
um china officially
labels these um these camps like at
education centers in the beginning and
and
then when the first information came out
about this camp system
china flatly denied that these camps are
happening but they are on such a big
scale and
according to reports by experts of the
united nations and which
are quite credible there are up to a
million people
being held in these camps and so we're
talking about a huge
system of thousands of of of camps like
on a huge scale which have been built up
and um these these camps are clearly
visible through satellite images some
even through photos from outside and of
course by the reports of people who
managed to escape who have family
members there
so we're talking about a huge massive
system
and in these camps these people are are
very strictly indoctrinated they they
they're basically treated like
like criminals um they they they're not
allowed
to freely of course not eat not to leave
but not even to talk
freely to meet people freely it's
basically like
living in prison but not only in prison
but being basically they have to sing
and um communist songs they have to
praise the leadership they have
denounced their religion
and they have to basically accept
that the chinese culture and the chinese
han
culture is superior to their own culture
they have to learn chinese like putin
they're the main chinese language
and which is just one part of basically
of a huge campaign
to eradicate the culture of these people
so
in the schools students are not allowed
to speak their own language
anymore and people are not allowed to
dress in a way they want
and apart from this in in whole of
xinjiang and i
managed to travel for a few weeks um
undercover through this region and
um you have like police checks basically
every few hundred meters when you're in
the cities you have
visible police which to shock the people
and to scare them to frighten them
if you travel to xinjiang and i've been
based in china for more than 10 years
i've been to tibet in other regions but
what i saw there is is not comparable as
anything else i've seen
in the end it feels like a huge prison
itself if you travel to xinjiang
um last question as we see more and more
graphic reports like the one that you
are highlighting
do you think pressure is going to grow
on china
to address this and to stop their attack
on the weaker population
i don't know what
or what can be done to make china change
their policies
but i think the scale and of this
human rights violation and basically
this kind of
like trying to eradicate
the the culture and the identity of a
whole population
um in this region is
it's not something where you can which
you can just ignore or which you can
just
go over to business as normal and you
have to
there have been things happening that
that international companies
like for example in the closing industry
they get their cotton from this region
and i think people have to think if you
as
if your consumer for example in in
europe right now
i think it's it's worth not to think
only about environmental things when you
buy products but it's although
so important that you think about
political consequences a lot of products
come from there
um this campaign what china is doing
there it's
not like a short it doesn't look like a
short home campaign it doesn't look
something they started a few months and
might stop in a few months
there's massive infrastructure you have
to imagine thousands of camps like this
electronic supervision with
streets going there and it's a huge
system of camps
which apparently is is
has been built to stay there for a long
time
so this seems to be what we're seeing
right now the
long-term solution that china has in
mind for the uighurs
and it's difficult to see a change there
because it's connected to the top
leadership in beijing
to xi jinping himself who gave basically
the orders
to to to act in this way and to suppress
the people in this way
so politically it would be a huge
change for china and it's not so easy to
imagine right now
thank you for joining spectator tv
harold and for drawing attention to
these horrible human rights abuses
now back to europe eu leaders are
arguing over a new law in hungary
that bans any display of homosexuality
in schools to under eight teens
victor orban is supported by countries
like poland while countries in western
europe are outraged
the german chancellor angela merkel
would usually guide the eu through these
arguments but she's stepping down in
september after the federal elections
who will take her place and can they
keep the union together
james forsyth our political editor
speaks to spectator contributors
jonathan miller and katya hoyer thank
you kate
well on friday angela merkel comes to
check us as part of her farewell tour
she is leaving the european political
stage
and it is remarkable to think back who
was in charge when she first became
chancellor of germany and there is no
doubt that her departure will create a
vacuum at the top of european politics
now what and who fills that much that
will depend on what happens in the
german elections this autumn
cassia what's your sense of what the
most likely kind of governing
combination
is in germany after those elections well
there's been an interesting short period
really where the
greens uh briefly looked as if they were
going to
uh clinch it and become the largest
political party but i think that was
very much due to the
excitement that people felt you know at
the time
um people wanted change there was some
disappointment that marco souda the
bavarian
minister president um wasn't going to be
the chancellor candidate for the for the
christian conservatives
and i think all of these things
compounded together to create
the sort of brief moment of of
popularity of extreme popularity for the
greens
and that seems to be wearing off a
little bit so as they're now polling
around about the 20
that's still a lot better than the in
the last election um
but nonetheless a lot less than they
need to become the leading
uh party or the most popular party in
the election so my
my feeling is that lashed is slowly
winning
back the conservative voters not
necessarily because they're entirely
pro lashed but i think there seems to be
a sense of you know people are
kind of almost resigned to the fact that
he is now leading the conservatives and
they're they're not necessarily warming
to him but warming to the idea of
of perhaps less exciting conservative
politics than
than they would have had under uh marco
soda so
it's my sense that he is going to um
lead the most popular party um and
therefore gets the first crack at
forming the new coalition it's actually
a more
perhaps interesting question what he's
going to do with that given that all the
current
combinations that are available don't
seem to be the ones that he won so that
there doesn't seem to be a majority
for uh conservative and and the liberals
to work together as has been sort of the
traditional
uh combination in in germany um and
equally that does just about seem to be
a majority for the greens to work with
the liberals and
and the social democrats which would
exclude basically the largest political
party if the if the conservatives get it
so
there's going to be an interesting
question afterwards what happens given
that in 2017 that was the longest period
afterwards
um of of the german government to you
know that the german government took to
form itself after an election
you can sort of sense just how
complicated and how much um
you know acro money there is between the
political parties trying to form a
coalition afterwards will
will be the interesting uh bit of that i
think
jonathan we know that emmanuel macron
wants more europe he wants to kind of
uh deepen the so-called hamiltonian
moment
that we saw we know lachet is cautious
about continuing with that
and but then you look at macron's own
election next year
what do you think macron's chances of
forging the kind of europe
he wants to after angela merkel's
departure are
well macron obviously has is preoccupied
now with his own political
survival and i think he uh
is a european ideologue without much
question he wants a deeper europe he
reaches for europe and therefore he's
going to want to see uh
a german in charge who shares his vision
uh but also i think macron's ambition is
that uh
as as a senior as a senior boy
that uh that he will be calling the
shots more from now on
than he did with merkel who sort of
pretended that she was in partnership
with
macron but never really treated him as
an equal
i think macron's primary preoccupation
at the moment is getting re-elected
himself
and where do you think his chances stand
on that after the recent regional
elections which
which were bad for le pen but also bad
for him
they were an extraordinary result i i
think you can say that the only thing
predictable
about french presidential politics is
that it is
wildly unpredictable uh who would have
imagined uh
five years ago that macron was going to
sweep all before him and become
president the uh the mainst the
macron and marine le pen are spending a
lot of time now saying these uh regional
election results don't matter
um macron's uh presidential majority
and le pen's front rasamblemore nacional
both failed to carry a single department
and uh and so they're now turning to
blaming the voters for not showing up
but i think there is possibly a dynamic
here and that is
that le pen it's been assumed that the
pen who is
certainly macron's preferred opponent
was going to get through to the second
round
where macron would predictably defeat
him
defeat her in fact it's not by no means
clear now that that's going to happen
there's a strong possibility that
le pen will not get through it in the
second round which could leave
macron facing uh a more conventional
uh center-right candidate who may not be
eliminated as francois fiona was last
time
by a a judicial process so
everything's to play for but i would say
the odds of
the sort of certitude of a macron uh
victory has
lengthened considerably and it will now
see possibly a much more conventional
election
in which the pen having failed once
before
may not even make it through to round
two now katya
one of angela merkel's skills has been
compromised
lots of points in her chancellorship you
know the european project has
has appeared in real trouble there was a
the moment when greece almost left the
euro
but angela merkel has found a way to
kind of patch up differences
and and keep the show on the road um
when you think of the european
council last week and uh mark rutter
saying that the hungarians should leave
the eu
xavier bettel of luxembourg uh going
after victor orban
over uh over his new laws on
homosexuality
and teaching it in schools do you
how do you think these cultural visions
in europe
are they going to deepen uh over the
coming years
and and how you know who in europe can
kind of bring these two
cultural signs together i'm not
convinced that can be done i mean i've
i've always found miracles uh
path of of compromise quite um you know
it was always going to be a temporary
thing and i think there was almost a
sense in the german government that
something would eventually happen
um you know to solve this problem and in
the meantime it's sort of hold out and
shine and bridge the gaps between the
two
but when you look at you know how
hostile the response has been
from the eastern european uh states
towards the
uh failed sort of um arrogance really of
the of the west you know and especially
with germany that the rhetoric has been
quite you know extreme from some of the
leaders in in eastern europe um
i'm not sure that can be done in
perpetuity by whoever follows and i
think to some extent merkel has been
able to get away with it simply because
of her standing in europe because of the
longevity of of her reign and because of
the respect that she
held within germany so as for instance
within germany politics towards
uh kind of marcus politics really as the
popularity of that waned
merkel's own popularity somehow remained
stable and i'm not sure somebody else
can pull off the same thing so i think
if you continued with politics like that
you'd run
into problems within germany um as well
as in
in eastern europe simply because what
germany is trying to do as regards of
russia clashes automatically with with
the interests of of many of the eastern
european states
if you take the issue of of the
homosexuality laws introduced by
by hungary as one example there was very
very little indignation in germany when
russia introduced very similar
legislation in 2013
um and there certainly has not been you
know anything like the outrage
since about that and hungary or the
hungarian people are now
you know in a position where they're
saying why is it an issue when we do
this when
it clearly isn't with russia and you
continue to make
politics with them it's interesting that
um bearbook the leader of the greens
has already said that she thinks cuts to
hungary should be on the cards for
introducing a law
uh like that whilst um
you know basically the reaction from the
conservatives and also from the spd from
the social democrats has been a lot more
cautious and muted so i think the con
the
continuity candidate there lashed would
try and
perpetuate a course of compromise in the
way that mackel has been doing it but
i'm just not sure he's got the personal
gravity that merkel had to pull that off
in the long run
jonathan if i can finish with you
is your sense that the kind of european
political landscape you know who is
going to succeed
angela merkel as you know the de facto
senior states of europe but this won't
really be settled
until after the french elections next
year when we work out whether macron has
been
re-elected or not and we know who the
new german chancellor is
well i think it's all up in the air i
think macron certainly would love
france to uh to be the senior partner
of course it's never going to happen uh
germany is just economically
too strong he
he his hopes uh that he can be
an equal partner never mind a superior
partner
have probably evaporated because uh
with britain leaving there's absolutely
no
counterweight to germany and germany
no matter who the leader is really holds
the prime
cards so
macron's ambitions are for europe he has
attempted to persuade
merkel to sign up to his european
renaissance
she signed a treaty with him in exodus
chappelle which
was pretty meaningless she's ignored him
and it suits her
you know i imagine that he with his
european um
obsession um dreams of being
some kind of new uh new kind of
bonaparte or charlemagne
but he's got a long way to go before he
even
retains the keys to the elysee and
that's uh what's uh
what's provoking conversation
amongst my neighbors and the political
and media elites in paris whether he can
actually hang on
and i think these regional elections
given the huge
kind of the abstention which was really
a kind of vote of
no confidence in any of the above but
with not a single victory
for macron and not a single uh victory
for le pen um are a wake-up call that
they've got to get back on track
and then there is obviously the question
of mario draghi of italy and his
uh desire to to to use his standing as a
former head of european central bank
to shift european politics thank you
both so much and i'll hand back to you
now kate
thank you james now finally let's return
to the story of the week
matt hancock's resignation a photo of
him in his
office first appeared in the sun but in
this week's spectator magazine the
journalist isabelle oakshot says she
turned down the story
because she was worried it was a fake
how did it get into her hands
what are the ethics of publishing
something like this and can video
footage really be trusted in the age of
deep
fakes isabel thank you so much for
joining me
so you turned down the scoop how did
this happen
no journalist likes to miss a scoop and
especially not me
since i absolutely pride myself on being
a scoop getter
and look the reality is i screwed this
up
i was sent one a single still image from
the cctv footage
of matt hancock about a week before the
story
ran in the sun and i looked at the image
and obviously since then i've looked at
it multiple times and my judgment was it
wasn't matt hancock it really did not
look like him
that is still the case it still doesn't
look like him additionally there looked
to be something a bit funny about the
image
it looked as if it had been slightly
doctored and look there's a lot of
rubbish
uh doing the rounds at the moment
journalists are always being sent
weird stuff by uh crooks and cranks and
conspiracy theorists and
you know your default position as a
journalist has always got to be
one of skepticism so i didn't think it
looked like him
i asked the person who had sent me uh
this
image uh whether we could get any more
on it but i
honestly i wasn't pushy about it because
i just didn't think it was him
so you can imagine my chagra when a few
days later this appeared as an amazing
scoop in the sun
so you were sent this small blurry photo
as you say in the magazine by an
important
contact and your immediate thought was
this is not the former health secretary
did you think about trying to verify it
or were you just
to yourself no no way can't be the case
um no so you know the conversation
continued with my contact in that we
agreed
that he was going to see if he could
have a look at the full video because my
contact had only been sent that as well
and my contact was going to go back to
the original source and say yes actually
we would like to see the full video
we're not sure it is him but can we see
the full video uh
and then we can take it from there and
the original source it said
yes okay no hurry uh you know and
that was where mata's rested but you
know and mayor cooper i didn't push it
and
you know honestly if i showed you the
image that i was sent i think you'd have
absolutely agreed with me that it
doesn't look like
matt hancock and you know it's only a
fool that rushes in in this situation
and gets very over excited and says yes
that is definitely
the apparently happily married health
secretary
cavorting with a foxy brunette in his
office
seemed pretty unlikely to me at that
point
was it unlikely as well because you
thought there's no way that the person
who designed
and has been enforcing these covert
rules has actually broken them
himself or are you quite familiar with
the behavior of politicians over the
years
to know that sometimes they do design
the rules for the public
that they don't quite follow themselves
yeah a really good question i mean
i've known matt hancock for at least 10
years
probably more not he's not a personal
friend but i've worked with him
professionally
on all sorts of political
stories and projects over the years in
his capacity as health section and other
roles that he's had
and um i have always seen him as a
pretty
straightforward type of mp there are
certainly mps that i've put in the
dodgy bracket i'm not going to name any
any names but there are mps that i
wouldn't have been surprised
uh if they've been up to all forms of no
good
uh matt hancock is not in that category
as far as i was concerned so
that wasn't what was going through my
mind when i saw the image it was simply
that
that doesn't look like matt hancock had
it looked like matt hancock i would have
you know certainly
been quite open to the notion that he
was doing something unexpected because
look you know this stuff happens
politics is a very heady environment to
work in
um i've seen the way that people change
when they get
into parliament you know there's
something sort of quite strange happens
when people
become mps and the westminster village
is
just that it's a village in in a secure
zone and
i think mps sort of feel that they've
entered a different realm when they're
in there
and that different behaviors are perhaps
more more acceptable in some way or
they're less likely to get caught and
you know there's the whole power thing
as well the headiness of it all
and i think that can be quite difficult
uh almost impossible actually
for partners that are not in the
political world to understand it's
very intoxicating that environment and
if you are going home very late at night
to a partner that
is not part of that world then it's
really quite easy
to uh to see how you begin to lead quite
separate lives i'm not saying at all
that's what happened uh in matt
hancock's case i wouldn't dream of
uh you know sort of speculating on what
happens in his marriage but i'm just
saying more
widely you know it is very very
difficult maintaining relationships
for politicians because of the
kind of uniqueness of the environment in
which they work
you write that you only received a photo
no video footage
but even if you had i imagine you might
have been worried that it was a deep
fake as technology has developed to the
point where
you can create really convincing videos
showing someone saying something or
doing something that they've never done
this creates quite a journalistic
conundrum and it's going to require even
more scrutiny on the part of journalists
in the future isn't it
absolutely and this stuff is getting so
sophisticated
i mean i'm on a number of um lockdown
skeptic
whatsapp groups um and some of them are
entertaining and some of them are
informative and some of them are
slightly kind of creepy and a lot of
weird stuff goes on though
it gets into circulation and earlier
this week there was
quite a convincing um fake what
to me was quite obviously a fake
document which purported to be
an email from chris whittie
circulated to a number of people on
stage it looked
quite official and as far as some
members of the whatsapp group
were concerned this could have been a
real thing now
i as a journalist dismissed it instantly
although i have to say
since my little matt hancock
embarrassment um unfortunately i won't
be able to dismantle
dismiss anything uh quite so casually as
i did
with him and you're right it is it's a
minefield for journalists because
you know 99 times out of a hundred
if your instinct is telling you this
can't be real
um you know as a journalist the story's
too good to be true
it usually is too good to be true it
isn't true
but unfortunately the one time out of a
hundred
maybe it is true uh so it's sort of
quite resource
intensive you know it's not actually my
day job to go pursuing these stories i
have a living to make doing other things
but if it is your day job i think you
could easily spend rather a lot of time
verifying material and trying to work
out whether it is or isn't
uh genuine and or whether it's an
extremely sophisticated fake
and there are now multiple inquiries
going on as to how this footage was
leaked
you were behind a story in 2019 that
also led to big questions about how
sensitive material
is leaked kim derek britain's then
ambassador to the u.s calling donald
trump
inept and incompetent tell us what
usually happens in these inquiries
well i i don't think there really is a
usual
except in so far as if the the original
source is lucky what
usually happens is that they after an
initial kind of
enormous drama and fuss it kind of goes
away
um so you know each story is different
i've been
the recipient over the years of a number
of caches of highly sensitive
information
and it really depends um what category
that falls into you know if it's
classified documents
it's clearly treated very differently to
whether it's somebody's just somebody's
private emails
all of these the publication of all of
these raises quite
difficult legal questions for for
newspapers
uh slightly less barriers of just
putting something online but nonetheless
they're a consequence you can't just
whack stuff onto the internet
with no consequence whatsoever so
you know typical course of an inquiry
will be a lot of noise from number 10 of
downing street saying we must look into
this and lots of huffing and puffing
and then you know a sort of rather
half-hearted inquiry takes place behind
the scenes
that ends up identifying precisely
nobody
and it may well be that this is exactly
what happens in the case of the
matt hancock cctv footage
so do you think there's a chance they'll
find out who leaked the
video or do you think it's much more
likely that this will remain
a big question mark well i actually
don't really want them to find out
who leaked the video because i think
that the person that leaked the video
did quite a public service i believe
that they were motivated simply
by wanting to expose what they saw as a
hypocrisy
of the health secretary or the then
health secretary's behavior
i don't think well in fact i can tell
you for sure that this wasn't
some kind of sophisticated or elaborate
political plot there were no
cabinet ministers involved there wasn't
any there's no evidence whatsoever of
any kind of foreign power being involved
and these were some of the more
outlandish
theories that were doing the rounds uh
in the immediate aftermath of that
footage
coming out no the source of this story
was simply somebody who didn't like the
what he was seeing
he or she um was seeing in terms of the
health secretary's behavior
quite literally behind closed doors
and i actually don't have any more
information than that but if i were to
speculate
it would be that the source the original
source of the footage
has perhaps found the measures that the
health secretary
has imposed or had imposed on a
population-wide basis very difficult to
stomach it could have been somebody who
was having difficulties seeing their own
loved ones perhaps had a
elderly parent in a care home or any
number of other circumstances that have
been incredibly difficult for
so many people over the lockdown and saw
that
the uh the then health secretary was uh
creating a special rule for himself and
his mistress and just didn't like look
at that
well to viewers at home be sure to check
out isabelle's article in this week's
magazine
isabelle i'm sorry that you missed out
on the scoop but here's wait for the
next one
thank you for joining spectator tv thank
you
and that's it for this week if you
enjoyed this episode why not subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel so you
never miss out just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of the video
and the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
thank you for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
you